this truly is a day of mixed emotions
for me I'm sad that old Gus is leaving
but it allows me to help Andy restart
his life as pioneer Hall's new shoeshine
guy well I've been listening to you
boring speeches for the last 50 years
and now it's time for you to listen to
one of mine you know a day like this
makes a man reflect upon his life and
I've come to the conclusion that I've
completely wasted mine and just for the
record I never ever liked being called
old guts I didn't understand it when I
was in my 20s and I sure hate it now so
go to hell every single one here screw
Pawnee and screw your damn shoes yeah
what the hell are you doing Andy and
Ann's family shoeshine I thought I did a
nice ring to it
my god look mark has been really cool
about all this and you're throwing it in
his face look I just don't have feelings
for you okay I said it what do you want
me to do not mention those feelings to
your boyfriend yes and you might want to
take these pictures down oh my god take
those pictures down what now give me the
bikini one the teeny one bikini one
Andrew looking good business is booming
yeah hey bro how about you a little dog
waxing it's only five bucks and I'll let
you cut in front of this guy what come
on beat it this is Ron Swanson we're
talking about hex you shouldn't let your
friends cut in line it's not good
business oh you know what else isn't
good business
I guess my friend right I'm saying you
shouldn't let your friends cut in line
all right
sorry I'll do this
next that's a good shoeshine
what the command I have been writing a
lot of songs about shining shoes lately
I tend to write about what I'm doing I'm
talking about writing about what I'm
doing now I'm singing about talking
about writing about what I'm doing
that's the hey Technos practice in it
isn't that polish gonna get on people's
bus when they sit down yeah okay listen
I'm having a party and I thought maybe
you could help me with serving and
taking people's coats I pay like 10
bucks an hour oh good I'm good to go
that sounds great
I'll see you there all right Mandy hey
Kyle you know way before you sat down I
notice did you have some kind of stain
on your ass or something what was that
oh no no you're good I don't fall
all right guys Andy I've been here for
half an hour dude my shoe shine Kyle I'm
gonna lose my on you if you ask me one
more time April you're like an angel
with no wings so like a person actually
there are a couple cool places in here
let's go again now let's roll okay
and II recently diagnosed himself with
what he calls shoeshine head it's when
you shine too many shoes and the fumes
create a thunderstorm in your brain
cures include coffee cheeseburgers and
napping on the floor hey well I have you
here what do think of this scrote ation
marks come on there's no one in the
world who's gonna do a better job for
you than a pool either you hire him back
or I quit you don't work for me
and I never will sir good day uh-huh
that's great I'd love to hear all about
your family vacation Hey oh thank god
get out Kyle hello birthday girl got you
a birthday present
really yeah I I wrote you a song score
that's a card not tell him but I'll give
you a clue it's named after a month out
of the year so April no that would have
been way better well whatever I can
rewrite the lyrics oh my god you don't
remember anything in heaven less than I
do
no Wow for once it's an who blacked out
drunk and not Andy okay oh my gosh this
is that's really dangerous please tell
me this is going to be so fun
why didn't you dangle until I finally
reveal that we did not make it oh damn
it November your bangs accused
member you boys as a flute November
let's pretend skies from hearts but
spread our wings and fly on a date wanna
go on a date with you November
that song is about April so you love
April and she has a new boyfriend right
you got all of that from a picture and
he told me yesterday well yeah how did
it go today was super fun it was yeah
do you have a list for tomorrow you want
to do this again tomorrow yes I do
I mean it's the deal right I got a do
for a whole month and then you're not
gonna move to Indianapolis better be the
only person in kiss today damn I'm
positive that you are hey you gotta hear
this hilarious story that he's telling
me tell her what happened my identity
was stolen tell her about the accounts
they were frozen this is awesomely
perfect burly just moved in with his
rich girlfriend and we need help with
the rent we have a couple house rolls oh
yeah sure of course
you can't use the front door you have to
climb in through the back window no
personal phone conversations if you ever
speak to me in Spanish
please use the formal usted and no
electricity after 6:00 p.m. you can use
as much free electricity as you want
it's free game a couple new rules if you
ever watch a sad movie you have to wear
mascara so you can see whether or not
you've been crying there's no noise a
lot of Mondays and no TV after breakfast
its head to toe no we leave the TV on
all day long some burglars think that
we're home but we're not which is my
idea that I'm trying to patent so you
want to move in tonight yeah sure that'd
be great oh my god
oh man I love this song
[Music]
oh man you really screwing this out I'm
gone for one day this entire shoeshine
stand falls apart everything I built
jump up here I'll show you how it's done
your problem is you're thinking too much
wow you're really good yes I am
when I come back here in a few weeks I
don't want all my regular customers to
not be here waiting for me somebody
screwed it up huh thanks no problem see
you later kid one year from now you Andy
Dwyer will no longer be a shoe shyness
Kyle beat it I'll make out with my wife
now but you've only done half of one of
my shoes here now I haven't done
anything scram kid
your champion little horse and you're
dead you're the champion of death you're
the champion of death hello Andrew
what's new um a whole lot check this out
I just invented it
super straw
you